in his push to reopen the country the
president is criticizing
one of his own experts dr anthony fauci
weisha zhang is at the white house for
us wija good morning
what does the president have to say good
morning tony and good morning to
everybody president trump continues to
push the country to quickly bounce back
and says he does not consider that
happening
without reopening schools claiming the
virus has had very little impact on
young people but you're right
his own top health experts disagree
lucky wants to play all sides of the
equation
president trump pushed back against the
warning dr anthony fauci delivered at a
senate hearing the day before
there is a real risk that you will
trigger an outbreak
that you may not be able to control we
don't know everything about this virus
and we really better be very careful
particularly when it comes to children
i was surprised by his answer actually
uh because uh
you know uh it's just to me it's not an
acceptable answer
especially when it comes to schools but
a new cbs news poll finds that most
americans trust dr
fauci though his unfavorable rating
among conservatives has increased
since april the country needs guidance
of the nation's best medical and
scientific experts
these literally are matters of life and
of death
as democrats demand more guidance from
the federal government
today the administration's former top
vaccine researcher rick bright
will testify before our house committee
that if the response is not
ramped up 2020 will be the darkest
winter in modern history
breit filed a whistleblower complaint
claiming he was removed from his
position because he pushed back against
the administration's embrace of
hydroxychloroquine
cbs evening news anchor norah o'donnell
interviewed bright
and asked him about the president's
accusation that bright
is a disgruntled employee i am not
disgruntled
i am frustrated at a lack of leadership
i am frustrated at a lack of urgency
to get a head start on developing
life-saving
tools for americans
i'm frustrated at our inability to
be heard as scientists as the number of
virus
infections continues to rise so too does
the number of americans who have lost
their jobs
struggling with economic hardship on
wednesday federal reserve chairman
jerome powell warned of lasting damage
to the economy
if congress doesn't pass additional
stimulus measures
the scope and speed of this downturn are
without modern precedent
significantly worse than any recession
since world war ii
house democrats have already put forward
another three trillion dollar stimulus
plan but republicans have already said
it is dead on arrival this afternoon
president trump will visit a ppe
distribution facility in allentown
pennsylvania he plans to announce a new
initiative to
replenish the national stockpile by the
fall
anthony weija thank you